how how connected were you to like
kind of what was going on in the hip-hop
scene like coming up like obviously you
were a star on the basketball scene like
yeah there's no secret you were probably
going to make it to the league right
right right um when you're that talented
you probably are granted access or
opportunity to be around
you know maybe the nozzles the prodigies
of the havocs of the world were you able
to connect with that scene at all coming
up well i was always in the streets
anyway playing basketball you know i'll
be out to 12
2 a.m 3 a.m you know the houses is
outside doing anything
you know what i mean i'm outside doing
my thing you know i mean playing
basketball and when i'm finished doing
what i do i'm going to chill with my you
know with the with the people on the
block yeah so i wasn't necessarily like
into
i wasn't like around a rap crowd but we
just family
so you might see havoc
walking out his building
you know
my family um
they did their time already and i always
ask them can i tell some stories i
always ask anybody before i tell a story
but like you know my family live on the
same uh same floors have it have a door
right here i think havoc was 3a
and then i was
3b or something like that right back
here you know and my family moved moving
product out to crib and stuff like that
but this is right and then at that time
about 1993
havoc and his brother killed an rp
killer b i know
kill of me when he when he wasn't killer
b you know what i'm saying yeah 93 i
feel like that was even before juvenile
hell low-key that's for sure yeah
i remember killer bee when he used to
have a smile on his face
and then one day i got back home
i got back home one day i was a you
i get back home i go back on the block
everybody on the bench i go to the block
and i see killer
over there just like mean mugging
and i'm like
damn something happened to killer today
but but then when i was asking my boy
he's like nah he's for the last year you
know he's been like kind of just like on
some gangster [ __ ]
so
then i got accustomed to that killer
um
you know and it was kind of awkward and
then shortly after that he you know um
he died shortly after that
um but you know i grew up on the mob d
i'm from 10th street though
i'm from the block then the knives block
is like
diagonal from mine then you got like m.c
shan and molly mall of course and you
got you know mega
you know on the 40 side shout out to
cormega yeah nature
was big noid from qb no
yeah hit my mom my mom remember
screwball yeah screw up so my mom know
your mom and twin mom
shout out big twin they all with best
friends
so trying to be spent night at my house
um sometimes i remember we had a lot of
mice in our house so twins come over
r.i.p big twin so the twin come over we
they kill the mice for us
we be little kids running to run in
front of mice wake wake twin up he'd
kill a mice
um knowing to be spending the night
we'll go to their house and then screw
ball hostile rp hostile yeah
that's my brother-in-law he got a baby
by my uh
by my sister three babies i remember
that album that they came out with i
want to say
what the [ __ ] it was like the the
cartoon yeah the ball yeah that [ __ ] was
hard that's one of the greatest shows
that's one of the most slept on albums
i'm not talking about like in the
history i just mean even in hip-hop
people sleep on that house incredible
yeah but but if you're not it's like me
listening to like you know somebody from
houston
underground some underground qb [ __ ]
right it's underground it's one of the
greatest qb albums like nas obviously
has the greatest qb album mm-hmm and i'm
pretty sure he's out but then you got
mob deep so you can easily say nas is
like his top three albums one two and
three but you can also make an argument
that like i don't know i think the
infamous is probably
i would take the infamous over uh
everything except illmatic and
stillmatic was pretty stillmatic and it
was written
he's that's what i'm saying so you guys
so the so the infamous is for three or
four because the infamous is
damn it's so it's some short ones
and the infamous i feel like probably
even if we're just talking about an
album based on qb
it's probably higher than stillmatic as
far as just what was being talked about
well when you got it
i just mean in terms of like the energy
of where of of like
queen's bridge
because the infamous had that energy
that like felt like they recorded that
[ __ ] in the projects no no for sure
[Music]
yeah i would put infamous over
stillmatic we're talking about just like
queensbridge
queensbridge like it's a lot of great
albums obviously illmatic
yeah was incredible it's my favorite
album ever that's an incredible album
then you got um
then maybe the infamous them for missus
but then you got but then you got
stillmatic it was written too man you
got it was written so then but then you
got murder music
so i think like murder music was amazing
infamous is either like two or three
right it's like two it's like two or
three yeah shout out to mob dude you
know what i'm saying then you got
screwballs and you got iron three album
they got one of the great then you got
um the realness with mega i should say
even hnic shout out to the nation
keep it thorough is one of the best
beats ever this is what i'm saying so
shout out to alchemist